come on come on gum maths right here go
all right one big step up and shoots and
it's gas yeah 3 you're so good at this
this is the best game ever
can would you say we're expert marksman
well we have our moments herb we have
our moments but we could we could be
better I i agree i think we could be
better marksman and I also think we
could be better drivers you have to
shoot me out of the air much in the same
way that you would shoot a clay pigeon
or skeet I'm ready I'm ready let's do it
so cam this is GTA skeet shooting okay
let's do it I think I'm gonna have to
know which side you're coming from
either on the left whoa okay right all
right now I see the height you're gonna
come of that okay go around all right
gonna hit the gym there we go oh oh oh
okay oh don't do it oh is that you out
of our babo i think that means i get
appointees you get a point well done
well there's life tell ya amazingly you
didn't kill me not even takes that okay
sorry sorry sorry did you hurry up its
duck dog but gun keeps going off as well
all right you ready I'm coming right oh
dear no I'm not oh god I had a little
crash alright it's nothing serious I'm
just gonna take a little don't shoot me
I'm just whipping around the side here
yeah Oh God sounded terribly this all
right here we go okay jump here comes
job oh oh I missed I landed on the from
the crash mat okay I'm gonna mix it up I
go the other way Oh like it it's foley
to catch me I'll thank you pal thankee
thankee getting really good at this
driving oh god oh god I can see semi
really good at her exited better fabric
turn it's coming around bring it around
bring it round it's the jump oh it's
close another duck survives all right my
turn my turn thank you friend for real
though you are several gone rogue I'm
ready for you okay and hell yeah awesome
lovely shop you gonna try and hit me I
got rice you get this guy actually you
ready bringing me too easy but and pull
oh no that somehow missed you how many
ducks we got left we go
we got a couple of ducks left all right
I'm I'm sedition there I'm ready for
this I see down there he just keeps
drift drove real blood around the shack
fit it's pretty dark yeah Phil a duck
blood ducks have a lot of blood in them
huh so much here we go oh oh okay way
off sorry I was way off it's all right
just getting my a min nailart and pull
Josh lovely show duck is down all right
here comes a duck ok and pull Oh out of
the sky lovely show its yaw lovely shot
well hunted huh good hunting sir I'm
coming at you again that looks or just
have a we smoke calms the nerves yeah
diazepam I like to smoke after all right
this duck is coming in yeah ducks comin
in ready else cook duck skanky the duck
is goes revenge anything yeah thank you
thank you you're welcome you keep
flapping little bit oh god damn flap
flappity flap flappity flap he this but
coming here happy bird flappybird oh i
mistrust me they hardly jumped at all
okay it's gonna have a little cigarette
as well that was pretty tasty okay I'm
not like I started smoking oh that's why
you don't smoke just wishing our DJ hey
wait wait wait wait five seconds okay
heading to top it up here we go [ __ ] oh
you got me hahaha winner oh that was fun
so can this one is quarry jump pigeon
shoot so so stand in the box and shoot
the bike overhead all right nothing's a
little different let's do it this duck
is ready to fly okay and pull oh oh
tough shot to shot this definitely a
tough shot and pull
Charlie going short easy oh god ow that
really hard all right you're so right
off we go and pull oh the gay no oh so
close that was very close yeah this this
works as well this works really welcome
down here come on line up on uncle's
right reloading it pull gosh lovely shot
there we go he's coming over Bernie I'm
ready I'm ready Rocky's airborne Oh Joey
destroyed me Oh lovely sure sure lovely
shot all right gotta survive this okay
here I come all right and pull oh oh oh
you got me as I landed I think no I'm
still alive so I'm going again I'm ready
I'm ready doc is getting his light sites
lined up Paul oh let's come off it up an
angle oh oh that's gone that's gone
horribly no I jumped up quite late yeah
I joked like over the bike at the worst
time ah shitty great [ __ ] right I'm
gonna take one of these bikes and down
ya go oh yeah I marked them with my
corpse there are a lot of bikes down
here and pull yours amazing lovely just
as you're letting go of the bike huh
take a step back
oh there's a heart annex love jump on
the bike I speed now ready for this I'm
ready Oh the music's building as well
this is perfect all the fire is there
yeah I'm ready here we go stunt time oh
are you copy oh the pyrotechnics are
still there all right I'll put one last
duck hunt for you what's that you ready
yeah ready I'm ready ready yeah ought to
be aiming I'm ready okay oh yeah here we
go here we go ah oh that's what she much
better let's see much better do that
again don't you think it and pull pull
oh I got the kill that was great so sad
this is a pretty good idea you jumping
off there and be shitty at you yeah but
we should really do this from like a
higher height and this is how we're
gonna do it can base jump pitch and
shock I'm so excited for this one tiny
is key to shoot the free-falling guy
with the RPG let's see if we can do that
all right seems that I might be the
shooter you are definitely the shooter I
think you are probably the jumping man
ok go for it add pull I'll see you I'm
falling oh I see I'm falling I'm falling
oh oh it's a good effort you fall faster
yes very fast I see ah i see what's
going on here oh man you can t hi ok i'm
trying to angle use you come in for a
landing oh oh missed good effort good
effort good effort as he comes around
I'm head this is hard 00 is the closest
one yes swing it swing it around swing
it around here oh oh oh bullets ow oh
don't you go see done yet you evaded me
though that was good move oh alright
worry all right coming down as I see
Island down coming down oh man look at
but ah you do your bit see far too thats
all you what these Ducks are coming down
prayer yeah you're gonna require all
your piloting 20 your parachute skills
to land in the right spot good start
it's uh okay Paul oh shoot that's all
right I'll try and get myself there I've
got this this guy I've got good feeling
about this we're gonna go jump off hey
are you gonna do tea oh I don't have a
parachute for God's sake okay here we go
jump and fill the sheet pull the sheet
I'll par [ __ ] either Oh what all right
fine I'll get more RPG my turn to fall I
am as ready as I'll ever do take a
little step off okay ah graceful fall
and going straight down the shade oh oh
you show me yes first time great choice
i am martha head did you see when Smith
or did you just dissed time it perfectly
I was a perfect time right going from
the same bit again ok ok here we go see
if you can do it again I think I call
that fluke ok ok climbing up a little
step off okay and yeah again turn for
two alright so I get me back further
down what's your fanny it tests your
skills now you know how long it takes me
to get to that bit ok she was to use
math to work at the right place to shoot
come on come on gun maths right here we
go all right and one big step off the
edge and shoots and it's yes no or three
you so good at this this is the best
game ever hello
whoosh whoa all right hey even get me
haha ah here we go we writes off he's
off not seeing it yet why oh yeah landed
it hahahahahaha good what I like right
beneath you see ya ya ya are you
building where's your gun face it my
guns like guns stuck haha I'll go
straight for you Oh God hey haha I made
it I do Oh hardly fair hardly fair all
right I've gone really far forward sorry
not oh good can get me oh you got me
fine work alright switcheroo I went out
with a play on play all right you're to
get it is you're in go go go and whoa I
see there we go coming down oh very
close huh no face cabral I didn't land
it are we got 26 seconds samurai okay
bear boo boo oh it's looking good oh yes
I did it I did it which with me roller
roller celebration eight seconds eight
seconds jump jump man jump I'm out I'm
out fish gets you be the best shot in
the world oh oh oh man that's fun oh my
celebration that's a wonderful
celebration thing of beauty
you